so continuing with our schedule on DC
rebirth related content Marvel you know
I guess all new all different Marvel
that kind of thing what you guys will
notice down in the description is that
I've changed a couple things and
initially I had one day dedicated to uh
to throwing things back to doing some
classic stories but what I wanted to do
is kind of extend this so you'll
basically see a classic DC story running
alongside DC rebirth and a classic
Marvel story running alongside all new
all different Marvel and the reason why
is partially because I don't want to run
out of content for all new all different
Marvel and DC rebirth but also because
there's still some great stories to be
told and so in addition to you know the
son of Superman and the whole you know
return or I guess escape from Dinosaur
Island what I want to do here is I want
to dip my toe into the Waters of
Superman Earth One now we're not going
to cover the entirety of this here
simply because of the fact that Superman
Earth 1 is unofficially divided into
story arcs and because it's a graphic
novel and it's so massive in size in
order to make it digestible for you guys
to be able to really pick up everything
that's going on and for us to be able to
have good explanations I'm going to take
Superman Earth One In arcs and really
just see whether or not people uh people
really seem to enjoy this and so again
if you guys really like Superman Earth
One uh leave a comment down below you
know post a like you know hit the sub
button and and let me know and if you
guys really seem to enjoy it then we'll
make this a weekly series until it's
finished and then we'll transition to
like Batman Earth one and super or I
guess a Wonder Woman Earth one and I
think Teen Titans has an Earth One
Series right now but again at this point
uh you know for those of you guys who
don't know or those of you guys who are
familiar rather with the Earth One
series bear with me for a second while I
run over this for those who aren't so
within the DC Universe uh there have
been a lot of reboots crisis on infinite
Earth uh Infinite Crisis final crisis
New 52 so on and so forth and one of the
big issues is that a lot of fans get
wrapped around the origins of characters
they get tied into characters and it
gets really uh irritating and really
daunting whenever reboots take place the
Earth one line of stories does not have
this problem and the reason why is
because the Earth one line of stories
are considered wholly separate from
everything going on in DC right now so
DC rebirth does not impact Earth One
think of it as something completely and
totally isolated and the reason why this
is so cool is because it allows DC to do
whatever they want to with Superman
Batman Wonder Woman so on and so forth
all the characters who will appear as
part of the earth one series it gives
them absolute freedom to craft their
stories however they want to and with
Superman Earth One of course because
Superman is a flagship character of DC
Jay Michael shinski kicked off the
entire Earth One premise using the
character of Superman now getting into
this one of the things that I love so
much about Jay Michael Shin's writing is
he focuses so much on character
development a lot people will look at
you know Spider-Man one more day and
they will say this is it's just one of
the worst things ever happened because a
Recon you know one of the most
significant marriages in the history of
comic books but when you get past the
premise of the story and you look at the
writing of Jay Michael trzinski it's
fantastic and he's like that every
single time when he wrote Silver Surfer
requium it was amazing writing he hits
the mark every single time and with
Superman it's it's exactly the same you
know there's no difference here
initially we pick up with Clark hint uh
boarding a train to metropolis and again
because this is Earth one this deals
with the early days of its character now
the cool thing about this is that the
Superman's origin is timeless right I
mean from the time he first showed up in
Action Comics in 1938 from you know the
time that Humanity collapses the origin
of Superman will be known people will
know that he's the son of the last son
of Krypton that he was sent home you
know sent away from a Dying World he
landed on Earth he was adopted by the
Kent he was raised and he eventually
became Superman it's a Timeless tale
what trzinski does is he does not take
the Batman approach here Batman's origin
is actually tied in almost immediately
with the beginning of Batman Earth one
with strusinski he takes us through you
know the early days of Clark Kent's life
and then wrap back wraps back around
with the origin story at the end of this
first Arc and what he tells us here is
that when Superman or I guess right now
when Clark Kent arrives in Metropolis
it's really about finding his way of
course he takes up residence in the
Metropolis Hotel and his entire you know
discussion with his mother is that for
him he just wants to find his way in the
world he wants to find his place in the
world now the reason why I say this is
so important the reason why I say
shinski is so good at paying attention
to character is for Superman and this is
one of the things that I love so much
about his character for Superman Earth
is not his home and it never was you
know Earth no matter what happens with
Superman whether it's Superman 1 million
where he becomes part of the sun he goes
you know into the source and he has all
these huge experiences at the end of the
day Krypton is his home but it's a home
he can never return to there's family
there that he will never be able to see
and so for him trying to make his way on
Earth is basically Superman just trying
to make it day by day is trying to fit
in as best he can and that's one of the
things that I always say with the
character of Superman he looks at Earth
and he he cannot say this is my home all
he can say is this is where I'm needed
he'll never be able to say this is where
I belong and so I I think that's one of
the cool concepts with him but again you
know when he arrives here when Clarken
arrives at Metropolis he's really just
kind of checking out the area he's just
kind of poking around and for him it's
getting a lay of the land you know it's
really coming to an understanding of
what Metropolis is about it's the the
small town kid moving to the big city
you know the person from some small town
Ranch in you know North Carolina moving
to Los Angeles you know it's it's
learning everything that goes on but
because of the moral compass that was
taught to him you know by Ma and PAW
Kint to be quite honest you know he also
understands the value of what it means
to contribute to society and to be the
good guy now of course as we would
expect you know someone walking down a
dark alley in the middle of the night uh
he's held a gunpoint by some criminal
and he uses his heat vision to basically
incinerate the gun and to send the
fleeing for his life you know not only
that you know the guy initially has the
idea of killing him but we also know
that if this were to happen the dude
would probably be incinerated so again
he basically just flees and so we also
get this continuation of Clark Kint
trying to find his place in the world
and we pick up with him trying out for a
football team now this is one of the
things that I really really liked here
because we know with super strength with
the ability to fly he can run super fast
you know sometimes he's faster than the
flash it depends on what story you're
talking about and when that story was
written the idea is he would easily
become a member of the football team and
that's what happens here you know the
the coach is uh is looking at you know
Clark Kint and he's a little
disappointed and the reason why is
because you know when he was informed
that Clark Kent was a very capable
football player when he was able to play
everything you know when he was able to
play offense defense you know the wide
receiver the safety The Tackle
quarterback halfback linebacker
basically all the key positions that he
expected Clark Kint to be a massive guy
but Clark Kent's just some really small
scrawny dude but the idea of the coach
is hey you're here we might as well see
what it is that you're capable of and
and Clark shows it in spectacular
fashion and this is this is kind of a
funny thing because you know with with
other writers we may have seen an
instance where they just glossed over
this or maybe Clark Kent was just
blending in and so he allowed himself to
easily be taken out but instead he
doesn't do that you know he lines up
against the biggest linebacker they have
you know the biggest defensive lineman
they have and he plows right through him
he catches the ball with the greatest of
ease you know when it comes to being
wide receiver it's the exact same thing
you know he just goes through there was
even one point where the coach simply
says you know everybody on on the
offensive line you know sandbag yourself
just let the defense run through and uh
let them all tackle Clark hen and let's
see what happens they all try to tackle
Clark hen and he runs through all of
them and so because of this the coach is
absolutely flabbergasted but realizes
that someone like this on their football
team is a guaranteed win and so he has
one of the guys grab a contract bring it
down and they are willing to agree to
pay him whatever it is that he's willing
to take now from here we shift over to a
science lab and and I'll I'll kind of
you know uh you know make all this clear
here in a minute as to why shinski is
doing this but we jump forward to a
science lab and within the science lab
uh we're told by the the person who's in
charge of it all that this is an
extremely difficult lab to get into that
is tantamount to the financial sector
and cfas for those of you guys who don't
know Certified Financial accountants uh
you got to go through three CFA tests to
work on Wall Street you know they're
progressively harder they're given uh
once a year I think uh to give you some
perspective a friend of mine graduated
college with a master's in finance and
he spent a year and a half studying for
the first CFA he spent another year and
a half studying for the second and
failed so they're extreme
difficult test to take but with this
we're told the exact same thing that
this institute only takes the top five
graduates from you know from any of the
best universities from Harvard from Yale
from Princeton and that's the top five
combined you know that's that's not you
know five from each school it's five
total just to show you how difficult it
it is to get into this institution but
what we're told here is that Clark Ken
has approached this place for the
purpose of of securing employment and
initially this guy's response is that's
preposterous you know not only are you
do you not even go through the normal
channels to do this but even those
individuals that we select spend 4 years
before they can even go into research
and development you know they basically
undergo four years of training before
they do anything real with regards to
our company and so clarant you know he
asked the question what are these guys
working on right now the guys are on the
other side of that wall what are they
working on and the guy says well they're
working on deriving electricity from
salt water and so Clark K just writes up
a formula and says go give it to him and
the guy's initial response is look man
we don't have time for for games and
Clark says look if you give give them
this formula I will walk away and you
know I will I'll I'll get out of your
hair and it's hilarious because they
take the formula you know the guy takes
the formula over to the scientist and
they immediately have the answer and
it's funny because they've been working
on that formula for about three years
they've been working on how to try you
know they've been working on figuring
out how to drive electricity from salt
water in 3 years Clark kin shows up on
their doorstep and gives it to them and
and so you know this guy comes back and
says hey look whatever you do do not
leave this spot you know uh I'm going to
make a few phone calls now the reason
why I said that I would wrap around you
know with this with regards to what
shinski is doing is he's showing us what
Superman is capable of and again this is
all really leading up to Superman
becoming Clark Kent you know and it's
going to be a really funny situation
because with regards to all these things
that he's doing I mean one you know his
Superman uniform his luggage is just
sitting in a closet the iconic uniform
that will stand the test of time as one
of the most recognizable symbols in the
history of the human race right now you
me the people who live before us the
ones who will come after us it'll be one
of the most recognizable symbols for you
know till the end of time and it's just
sitting in a closet because Clark Kint
doesn't think anything of it you know
for him it's just clothes it's just the
remnants of his life when he was in
Smallville and so again cinski tells us
that he's been offered all manner of
positions he's been offered jobs as one
of the best scientists he's been offered
jobs working on Wall Street you know
being a professional baseball player you
know working as a uh I guess as one of
the guys in charge in a construction
site but none of these make him happy
and that is the distinctive difference
that's the big difference here the
reason why ser is so good when it comes
to writing character as he focuses on
the character Superman could have been
any one of these things and for for
trzinski you know with Earth One having
so much freedom and so much lay leeway
on what it is that he could and could
not do he could have made Clarin a
construction worker and said well in
this reality he's a construction worker
and that's just the way it is but no he
ties into the history of Clark Kent
going to work for the Daily Planet the
difference with this is he gives us a
reason why it's not because he just
wanted to be a reporter it's not because
he always wanted to be a reporter it's
because he was going through through and
he was trying to find his way within the
city of metropolis and he comes across
an article that simply reads City Hall
Scandal and he takes the article out and
he starts reading or at least he buys
the newspaper and he starts reading it
and he starts going through you know
everything that's going on with regards
to the Daily Planet and eventually he
travels to meet Perry white for you know
for a resume that he submitted in a job
interview now at the same time we also
see that we encounter Lois Lane for the
very first time now this is also a
pretty funny situation here because we
would EXP expect this to be you know
love it first sight you know because
with regards to the whole Superman
Mythos almost always Superman and Lois
Lane are the power couple I mean Lois
Lane is the first lady of comics she's
the quintessential Damsel in Distress
you know with the exception of the new
52 we've never seen an instance when it
hasn't been Clark Kint and Lois Lane you
know the onew punch of DC Comics but the
issue with this is that because trzinski
is taking a different approach it's
they're not immediately smitten with
each other it's not as though Lois Lane
is like oh my God you know you know
Clark hin you're the most attractive guy
I've ever met but he's smitten with her
you know he's he's really attracted to
her now maybe it's because of of her
confidence maybe it's because of the
fact that she's intelligent but whatever
the reason is it doesn't really seem
reciprocated now this is basically Jay
Michael shinski tying back to the
original Superman Mythos and what I mean
is when Superman first appeared in
Action Comics of course Lois Lan was
there but you know if you go and watch
any interview with seagull and Schuster
they'll tell you that the original
intention was to have Lois Lane
absolutely despise you know Clark hint
in the beginning and be in love with
Superman and then eventually that would
change she wouldn't necessarily learn
his identity but she would learn to
become more respecting of uh of Clark
Kent and they would have a very close
friendship with one another at least as
close of friends they can get without
you know Clark Kint telling her that
he's Superman now we know in the post
crisis continuity we know that much
later on you know going into the end of
the 90s the Superman revealed his
identity to Lois Lane for the very first
time which was a very big deal when that
happened but the fact remains here you
know that that stazinski is not just
giving us this you know this
archetypical story of you know boy meets
Girls a boy and girl fall in love and
they live happily ever after he's giving
us real character development here he's
giving us real indication of who these
people are and so after going through
what it is that uh that you know I guess
going through Clark Kent's uh resume one
of the funny things that Perry white
says here is that because of the
internet everybody with a keyboard a
mouse and a Blog thinks they're a good
writer they you know they think they
know how to write good material and he
says that car K writing is decent enough
but he writes like he's holding
something back now we know that that's
Clark Kent just not revealing to the
world that he's Superman but this is Jay
Michael shinski telling us that you know
Clark Ken refusing to reveal his
identity to the world holds him back on
a personal level because he can't truly
be who he is you know that he has to be
a fake character I'm going to go out on
a limb here and I'm going to quote uh
Kill Bill the Superman monologue because
I've I've got this thing memorized for
those of you guys that never saw Kill
Bill volume 2 there was a great segment
where he started talking about Superman
and he said a staple of the superhero
mythology is that there's a superhero
and there's the alter ego Batman is
really Bruce Wayne Spider-Man is Peter
Parker when that character goes to sleep
at night he's Peter Parker he has to put
on a costume to become Spider-Man and
it's in that characteristic that
Superman stands alone Superman didn't
become Superman Superman was born
Superman when he gets up in the morning
he's Superman his alter ego is Clark
Kent and what are the
attributes the outfit with the big red s
that's what he was wearing when the Kent
found him those are his clothes the
glasses and business suit that's the
costume that's the costume Superman
wears to blend in with us Clark Kint is
how Superman views us and what are the
characteristics of Clark Kint he's weak
he's unsure of himself he's a coward
Clark Kent is Superman's critique of the
whole human race now the reason why I
ran off that quote is because that's
exactly what sosinski is building on
here that's what he's telling us here
that Clark Kent is is how Superman sees
the world he's how Superman sees
humanity and because of this he has to
hold himself back he cannot be someone
to Aspire to when he's Clark Kent he has
to be an everyday person and because of
that it presents a scenario whereby he
can't fully be himself he can't fully
write you know in a way that gives
people something to look up to he has to
write the same way everybody else writes
he has to write the world through their
eyes now with regards to him stepping
into the role of becoming Superman what
zinski does here is he again kind of
gives Clark Ken an existential crisis in
the sense that you know he takes a
second to sort of jump back to the
origin story now we don't get the full
origin story here because again like I
said you know it's it's Timeless we
don't you know we don't really need to
be told that Superman was shot away from
a dying planet we know that what we care
about is what happens next how good is
the storytelling when he gets to Earth
that's what we as Superman fans care
about and that's what shinski gives us
what he does is he flashes back to the
first time that Superman asked his
parents who he is why he's here where he
came from now what they say initially is
that they don't know they don't know the
answers to those questions you know they
don't know why he was here they don't
know where he came from all they knew is
that the two of them were just hiking in
the woods one day and suddenly there was
a sonic boom and there was a rocket ship
that crashed landed onto Earth now this
is a little bit different from what
we're used to in some Superman stories I
think in the new 52 they stuck with the
idea that um you know the two of them
were basically driving down the road if
we read Superman American alien we pick
up with Max Landis saying that uh you
know basically Ma and PAW Kint they they
had a child before but that child passed
away uh there have been some instances
where they just can't have kids you know
but for whatever reason they end up ad
adopting Clark Kent this is just another
instance where we see something a little
bit different you know where the two of
them are are hiking you know and Martha
and Jonathan stumble across you know
Clark Ken's body or I'm sorry his uh his
rocket ship and immediately take him and
uh and basically adopt him now for them
the idea is you know once the government
starts setting in you know once the the
FED starts to ask the question of you
know what's this rocket ship where did
it come from they immediately take
Clarkin and they adopt him as their own
Jonathan Ken also says is that he was
meant for something special that the
things that he's able to do the powers
that he possesses make him somebody
that's that's destined to do something
great but the problem with this is they
just don't know what that is they're
like any parent in any situation when
any child sits down and says why am I
here what's what's the point of me being
here it's the quintessential answer of
we don't know all we can do is guide you
the best we can and hope that you turn
out as great as we believe you are now
what we also do is we get some
perception of the fact that not
everything was Rosy for Clark hint it's
really only on a page or so but it's the
idea that he is that he's picked on that
he's made fun of by kids at school but
he basically references is what it is
that he was told by Jonathan that you
can't let your powers get the better of
you you can't just lash out you can't
let other people you know control your
actions that you literally have to keep
things contained because if someone
angers you and you punch them you will
kill them with your strength and so you
have to basically just let things roll
off you now this is an important lesson
that we learn in everyday life you know
I mean if everything everybody said
bothered everybody else well the world
just couldn't function you know like you
just have to recognize that there are
some people in this world who are just
miserable that their life sucks for
whatever reason and the only way for
them to find happiness is to try to make
other people miserable then that's how
this guy is that's how this bully is you
know like this bully is probably living
a life that sucks you know and the only
way that bully can be happy is to try to
make Clark Kint miserable but whatever
the reason is behind it we basically
kind of jump back you know to the
present day with uh with Clark Kent
traveling to a church and to the uh to
the grave of Jonathan Kent and he sits
down and he has this great
heart-to-heart conversation with his
dead father you know Jonathan can't
can't respond you know he doesn't say
anything it's really just you know Clark
talking to himself really as much as
he's talking to his dad and he says that
you know he's sorry for coming by so
late that he always knew his father was
a morning person but that he just wanted
to talk to him and what he says is that
he doesn't think he can be a superhero
he doesn't think that he can be a man
that can live up to saving the world now
this is why this is so great because we
always assumed that Clark Kent would
move to Metropolis we would assume that
he would see how bad the world is from
time to time and he would see Metropolis
as a city he can save he would Dawn his
Superman costume he would reveal his ey
you know reveal the fact that he's
Superman to the world people would look
up to him as something to celebrate and
he would be the Savior what shinski
tells us here is that was not the case
at least not in Earth one that Superman
didn't believe that he could do that due
to his experiences and being picked on
due to the fact that the world is simply
not ready for someone like him that he
doesn't think that he can be Superman
Because he believes that if he Reveals
His identity to the world if he shows
the world that he has power he'll
constantly be on the run from people
that want to kill him he'll be on the
run from the governments that want to
capture him from private companies that
want to capture him and use him for
their own ends he doesn't believe that
humanity is ready and this is again a
great reflection of how it is that Clark
Kint views the world and so what he says
is that he really wishes that his dad
was here to give him some advice but he
also says that he recognizes the
valuable lessons that his father taught
him and so essentially he says that he's
going to go about and live his life as
he can but at this moment right now he
doesn't believe he will be able to take
on the mantle of being a Superman
because he doesn't think the world is
ready for it yet but with that being
said we're going to go ahead and wrap up
this first story arc I really hope you
guys enjoyed it cuz I got to tell you
like Earth one you know the Earth one
line of stories some of the best damn
comic book reading you ever going to
have in your life Jeff John's uh Batman
I think I think Jeff John's wrote uh
wrote Batman Earth one is so good like
the Earth One stories are amazing if you
guys like if you guys have read Earth
one and you guys enjoy it post a comment
down below just be like Earth one is
amazing you know but if you guys are new
here to uh to Comics explain you guys
want to see more Earth one line of
stories make sure you guys uh drop a
like make sure you guys hit the sub
button and uh yeah leave a comment down
below let me know what you guys think
and I will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
he